du haut de ce bâtiment de marioupol ce
solde a brandi un drapeau tchétchènes à
l'éffigie de leurs dirigeants
sur fond musical dans cette vidéo
diffusée sur internet ces combattants
qui est chaîne affirme avoir pris le
contrôle des bâtiments officiels de
marioupol la mairie dément il s'agirait
du bureau du procureur du district de
libo bérézina située à 10 km à l'est du
centre de mario paul
mais depuis plusieurs jours les vidéos
de combattants pro russe dans la ville
se multiplient ici encore des
tchétchènes en plein milieu d'un échange
de tirs ce combattant et de gagner du
terrain
de l'entré deux il ne reste qu'un
immeuble
des scènes de guérilla urbaine dans une
ville ravagée par les combats où l'on ne
peut toujours pas compter les morts dix
jours après la taxe sur le théâtre de
mario paul où des centaines d'habitants
se protéger des bombardements
cette vidéo nous parvient aujourd'hui
elle montre des rescapés film est juste
après l'attaqué
la mairie et mais ce matin un premier
bilan
selon des témoins oculaires dans le
théâtre dramatique de marioupol environ
300 personnes ont été tuées à la suite
d'une attaque d'un avion russe après
près d'un mois de siège les 100000
habitants de marioupol manque de tout
sur ces images diffusées par les
autorités de moscou c'est auprès de
l'armée russe qu'il trouverait désormais
de l'aide alimentaire
survivre dans une ville disputée mais
désormais détruite à plus de 90%